[MUSIC PLAYING]
THOMAS MOCK: All right
so we'll get into it.
And thank you so much for
the introduction there, Rob.
As he mentioned, I work on
the customer success team
here at RStudio.
The basic idea is that I work
with our professional customers
to best use our professional
products, as well
as open source packages, in
their specific environment.
So I spend a lot
of time thinking
about integrating open source
with professional products
using data science at
scale in production
in your own environment.
And RStudio Connect
is really one
of the key players,
at least of ours,
in that field of getting
your data science
products off your laptop,
into production, and ready
for consumption in
your organization.
So a quick overview
of today's agenda.
I'll give you an overview of
Connect, an overview of how
R Markdown plays
together with Connect,
and then do a quick demo
of some of the examples
I'm showing today.
There's a lot of material
here that we've already
covered with other topics.
So specifically I'll be
focusing on R Markdown.
But if you're just
interested in using
RStudio products in
production, there's
actually a webinar on that.
There's Model Management,
Shiny in Production,
as well as RStudio
Team Quickstart--
where you can actually
try out Connect
without installing anything.
So maybe you think this
is interesting and want
to see what it looks like
in your own environment.
try it out there.
And lastly, the
solutions.rstudio.com website
will be hosting a lot
of examples I use today.
And that was intentional
in terms of--
I want you to be able
to see some of the code
that I'm using so that you can
understand just how quickly you
could go from using
something locally
to putting it out there.
So again, RStudio Connect--
what it is is a content
hub and execution engine
for all your data products.
So this could be things like web
apps, machine learning models,
as RESTful APIs,
dashboards, reports,
automatic emails or
custom emails, tables,
and visualizations.
Basically, anything you're
already creating in R
it makes it where you
can take those insights
and leverage them a
little bit faster.
So you can share it
widely, share it securely,
get it off your
local environment
and put it out there for your
organization to actually use.
And importantly, RStudio
Connect is fully interoperable.
So it will play
with any of the data
products you can make in
R. And additionally, it
can communicate with
things like R and Python
or R and Spark, Javascript,
Tensorflow, SQL.
All these things can be
integrated into the data
products you're creating.
So you have a nice platform to
push out all of these things
that you're making.
The basic idea of what it would
look like in your environment,
and this is just a
very simple example,
is you create something
locally, maybe
on your desktop in RStudio IDE
or RStudio Server or RStudio
Server Pro.
You then have
push-button deployment
to push whatever you create,
say a Shiny application or R
Markdown document, onto Connect.
Connect will then host it.
It will provide all the
scaling and security you need.
It can connect to your
file share system.
It could connect
to your databases.
And ultimately your
end users will just
access that content via
their own web browser.
So they really just
see it as a website.
But in reality it's a
hosted, on premise solution
for your group.
It could also be
hosted on the Cloud.
But the idea being that you
install the software wherever
you want it to be, and you
have full access and control
over its own security.
Now this being said, this is
a relatively simple example.
And when people start
talking about production,
you start thinking of
these massive environments.
Whether it's thousands
of users, or lots
of people hitting your
API calls, or just
doing things at scale.
And so for a lot of people
production is this buzzword.
Or this idea of putting
things into production
is scary for a lot of people.
And so I want to go
over how at least I
think about production
environments
and how we approach
this with Connect.
And how you can start
where you are-- maybe
you're more advanced, maybe
you're less advanced--
and grow within Connect.
So, what does
production mean to me?
I'll steal a quote
from Joe Cheng
that he gave at the
most recent RStudio Con.
"Production means a
software environment
that is used and then
relied upon by real users,
with real consequences
if things go wrong."
So specifically, this
doesn't talk about how big
the environment is.
It doesn't talk about
how widely it's used.
Just something the
business relies upon,
something the business is
using to either make decisions
or to gain insight about
some data science product.
And that's really the
ultimate goal data science--
is to inform a business
decision to provide
value of some type
for the organization
or for the individual.
Beyond that basic
idea, in my mind
there's some other
production needs.
So things like
scaling and execution.
You want to have
it be able to work
for your entire organization
if you wanted to, as opposed
to just locally on
your own laptop.
You want to have security
and access control.
So you don't want to just
put it out there for everyone
on the internet to access.
And even within your
own group, maybe you
want to have only Execs see
these specific materials
or only your data science
group see other material.
You also want to have
logging and visibility
into the applications
you've already
pushed out there or the things
you're using in production.
As well as logging
about the performance
or when they've been updated
or changes that have been made.
And as Garrett covered in the
last webinar, reproducibility
is also a huge component.
And with a code based
solution like R,
you're really focusing on
being able to reproduce
both that environment, as well
as the actual code that you
used to create your asset.
And lastly something I
think is really important
is the sharing and
collaboration idea.
So sharing in terms of--
you're creating something.
You spent a lot of time
on creating a model
or evaluating a model, making
some type of prediction,
doing some core
data science task.
And then ultimately you have
to inform somebody, or share
that with somebody, and have
a useful discussion with them.
Additionally, you want to
have collaboration with them.
So maybe you have to send
reports back and forth,
or collaborate back
and forth with someone
who doesn't use R. But
they're making big decisions,
but they may not be a coder.
So being able to bring
them into the fold
and give them an asset
that they can work with.
In the last part of that
sharing collaboration aspect
is discoverability.
So being able to
go onto your area
and find things of interest
that may be useful for your team
to make decisions.
Ultimately, the idea
here is-- production
doesn't have to be as scary
as it always comes out to be.
In So yes, there are
some environments
that are extremely locked
down, extremely complex.
They're serving thousands
and thousands of users.
And a lot goes into it
from a deadlock standpoint.
There's other people
who really just want
to take some type
of R-based product
and put it out there
for 5 to 10 people.
And the concept here is
that I have customers
on both ends of the spectrum.
Very small groups serving other
small groups, and other people
who are serving hundreds
or thousands of individuals
within their organization.
And that works for
both of these groups.
And as well as the
spectrum across them.
So in terms of what
Connect provides in
this concept is hitting on the
same points that I said before.
So scaling, execution,
high availability.
Basically, you can take
your Shiny application
or your R Markdown down and
scale that to organization.
Additionally, because Connect
can actually execute R code,
it can actually really run
your R Scripts or R Markdown
documents or your Shiny
applications for new people.
As far as the high
availability concept,
you can have multiple
Connect servers in a cluster.
So if part of your
server were to go down,
you have another
one ready to go.
Or if you just want to share the
load across multiple servers,
that's also possible.
Additionally, you have full
security access control
and visibility.
So you can bring your own LDAP,
Active Directory, SAML security
to authenticate users.
You have access control.
So at the application
or server level
you can specify
who can see what.
As well as have
applications that
are only for testing or
only for production use.
And lastly you have full
visibility in terms of-- you
can see what's been
published there.
And you can understand
what's being
used in your organization.
Additionally, from
the reproducibility
and logging standpoint--
I'll cover this a
little bit later.
But you have these sandbox
environments on Connect
where you publish something,
it tracks the R environment,
and tracks all the different
packages that are being used.
So you have this metadata about
the assets you're creating.
You also have logging about
both use of it and updates
to those assets.
And lastly you have full
sharing and collaboration.
So yes, you can now take
in R Markdown document
and just publish the finished
document out on the Connect
and then people can
access it via web browser,
which is a huge win
for a lot of people.
But additionally, it opens
up as an execution engine
where those people who
may not know how to code
can actually re-execute those
R Markdown documents or Shiny
applications to create
something they want to see,
without ever having
to go and bother
the data scientist directly.
And lastly you have
the collaboration
and discoverability.
You can actually
search around R Connect
and find things of interest.
Ultimately, Connect's
getting your data products
off your laptop and
ready for consumption
in your environment.
Again, when I talked
about security--
you have three major
levels of security
that I'd like to focus on.
So your server level,
just authenticated users
accessing your content.
So you can bring
your own security.
A lot of people are familiar
with Active Directory,
LDAP, SAML.
There's some other ones
there, but those are
the three big players we see.
You also have app level.
So you can restrict user
access to your applications,
whether they're
Shiny or R Markdown.
Kind of going in there
and filtering out
who needs to see what.
And lastly, you even have data
level access to specific things
even within an application.
So all these different
tiers of security and access
that you like to see in
your production environment.
As far as the
reproducibility, I hit on this
a little bit earlier.
But the big idea here
is that you really
don't want to create something,
put it out there, and then
all of a sudden not have
governance or understanding
of how you created it.
So you don't want to lose
the code, you don't want
to lose the information
about which package version
you were on, or which
version of R you were on,
or what were even the
system dependencies
that you were using there.
So importantly, the way
that Connect works is you
create an asset locally.
So maybe it's on a server,
through RStudio Server,
or on the desktop IDE.
So you write an
application, and you're
creating R Markdown document.
Whatever you're doing, you
actually bundle that together
when you click Publish.
So this is all
done automatically,
you just click
Publish, Connect will
bundle all that
information together
so you have the source
code, you have the metadata
around a specific dependencies.
That's pushed out to Connect.
Connect then unpacks the bundle,
with this packrat bundle.
And it actually re-installs
the specific dependencies
at the exact package
version you were using.
So the same version
of R, the same version
of the exact packages
you were using.
So you have this
sandbox environment
of exactly what
you want it to be.
Importantly, each data product
has its own R environment.
So this prevents breaking
existing deployed content.
You can have multiple versions
of R basically running
across your different assets.
Multiple different
package versions
running across your different
assets, if you wanted to.
We have a little
bit more information
here in the documentation,
in the admin
guide about package management.
And if you'd like to know
more about package manager,
we can also have
that discussion.
The next step I'd like to
cover is the deployment aspect.
So when people talk
about "pushing to prod."
The joke is always,
don't push anything out
on Friday afternoon,
you don't want
to just put something
out there into the world
and then disappear
for the weekend.
So people will think
very differently
about how they're
publishing or how
they're deploying assets into
their production environment.
For a group just
starting out, they're
ecstatic and super
excited about just
being pushed by deployment.
Just being able to create
something locally and basically
in a few seconds publish it
out and had it ready to go
and shared across
the entire group.
Other groups are very much
more about the governance
in the DevOps side,
where they want
to have man in the middle
or woman in the middle.
Just someone there who is
making a decision about
is this ready to
go to production?
So if that means code review,
or putting it into Git,
or continuous integration.
So I'll cover all
these options briefly.
The first option would be just
push-button deployment, which
is the default.
So within the IDE
you can actually click
this little blue button
and it will publish
things onto Connect.
At that point you could
still restrict access.
So maybe you want to
push it out, play around
with it on Connect, and only
you can access it at this point.
And then after the
fact, you could say,
OK, well this is running
well I'll allow access
to the rest of our audience.
And open it up to
the rest of the group
to use the data product.
Alternatively, you could
put things out through Git.
So you could have a
Git-backed deployment
where you're not getting
pushed by deployment anymore.
But rather you're actually
pushing something out
in a version
control through Git.
And then Connect is
calling out to Git
and installing it
directly from there.
So in this case
you publish it out,
RStudio Connect will
publish the initial version.
And then will actually update--
pulling different Git
updates onto Connect itself.
On the alternative side, rather
than having this one step
process, you could
have a testing and then
a production environment.
Or what we are going to
call a staging and then
a production environment.
So this case, you actually
publish your asset initially
into a sandbox staging
or testing environment.
So a different
version of Connect.
And only your DevOps
or data science team
is accessing at this point.
Or just dog fooding it,
testing it, making sure things
are rock solid.
Once it's gone
through that stage
you can then re-deploy it onto
your production environment
and let the rest of
your consumers use it.
Now that it's working properly.
So this would be a
little bit more complex.
But in reality, you're
still able to use
the same push-button
deployment here.
Alternatively, you
get the same idea
where you're pushing
things out into a sandbox
doing your user
approval and testing,
but after this you
actually will ask
IT to publish its production.
So now you're bringing in
an additional stakeholder
because you want to
have more governance
or you want to have more
insight into bringing
the rest of the
administration team here.
And they will actually then
publish it into production.
All these are valid ideas.
But the concept here
I'm trying to cover
is that Connect
is ready to serve
all these different
environments or approaches.
And lastly, another one would
be continuous integration.
So still doing your sandboxing,
your testing approval.
And then the request
is actually set
to merge into your
version control.
It goes to code
review, it's pushed out
to the master branch, and then
a continuous integration server
will actually publish
its production itself.
So something like Jenkins
will go out there,
pull the that's been updated,
and then republished it
onto Connect.
Going through this
relatively quickly.
Just again, the
idea that wherever
you are in your data
science journey,
Connect is ready to
meet you at that point.
Getting more off of
the administration side
and quickly into the
data product side.
Again I mentioned I'd be
covering a lot of R Markdown.
A lot of people are
familiar with R Markdown,
on their local environment,
writing reports, maybe creating
a blog or even creating
small websites.
And the idea being
that you can create
all these things but then where
are you going to put them?
And Connect can be that place.
Obviously you can
also host things
like Shiny
applications, which has
been covered in other webinars.
Or even putting a
model onto production
as a RESTful API, which has also
been covered in another link
that I shared in this webinar.
But the idea here
is that you have
a spectrum of interactivity
with your documents.
And Garret covered this
really well last week.
So I stole this site from him.
The idea of, you have this
spectrum of more interactivity.
So a local .Rmd that you're
working in interactively.
And then you knit it once,
and so it's not really
that interactive.
Maybe you have an
.Rmd with parameters.
So now can create many reports
from a single master report.
You could add an HTMLwidgets
for front-end interactivity that
doesn't require
a server back-end
and gives you all this fancy
Shiny-esque environment
or interactivity.
But you don't have to have it
hosted with a Shiny back-end.
And then you could fully put
a Shiny component onto it.
So have a flexdashboard
or a R Markdown
based source with Shiny runtime.
You've got a server in the
back-end that gives you
further interactivity.
And then all the way out to a
Shiny application which could
be a truly custom web app.
So not necessarily a
report or a dashboard,
but truly something that
you just created yourself.
Now, the idea being
that I'm going
to focus on the first
three points here--
basic R Markdowns, R
Markdowns with parameters,
and R Markdowns
with HTMLwidgets.
Specifically on RStudio Connect.
And this is why I like to
think about it as R Markdown
and production.
Not just using R Markdown
as your basic reporting
just for yourself.
But thinking of R Markdown as a
key player in your data science
environment.
And in your data science kind
of production environment
where you're using R
Markdown as a way to create
repeated jobs, or reports,
or automated emails.
All these different things
that can provide value
for your company that you
may not be using today.
So the basic idea of
an R Markdown report--
again I'll just cover
it briefly in case
you missed last week's webinar.
It's an open source R package
that produces high production
quality documents by integrating
prose with code and results.
Basically, you can write,
you can create code,
and you can create outputs
all within a single document.
So this is really useful for
data scientists who are already
using R and they want
to both create a report
and share the report
in a reproducible way.
It can create all sorts of
different output formats.
Everything from basic
documents, PDF, journals,
full-blown web pages, Word
docs, other Markdown formats.
You can do presentations,
whether they're outputs PDF
or is an HTML output.
Dashboards through
flexdashboards.
Full websites, or blogs, or
knowledge repos, and then
also full books.
Importantly, all of these
different output formats
can actually be published
and hosted on Connect.
So you can actually publish
the finished product.
As well as bundle the code
and the finished product
where it can actually
be re-executed
on Connect without having
to write additional code.
Get to the next one.
There we go.
So with Parameterized
Reports, taking the next step
from R Markdown.
The idea here is that you
take a single R Markdown,
write a function
around it, and then you
can loop through or use
a map function from purrr
to create multiple
versions of this report.
So this is just a fake
report I put together.
The idea here is that your
rendering a specific R Markdown
document.
You're listing some
parameters, so these parameters
tell you that state
and year for it
will be generated on the
fly based upon your inputs.
And then you're creating this
output file as an HTML output.
So you write this function.
You specify your input.
So there's four different inputs
here, four states repeated,
and then multiple years.
And then you can knit
this report locally
four different times.
So this is really
powerful in terms of,
you can create multiple reports
on your local environment
really quickly based
off the same code.
The next step with
RStudio Connect
is you can take the same
parameterized report,
publish onto Connect
with the source code.
And someone who doesn't
have R installed
on their local machine,
or doesn't even
know how to code in R,
and they're actually
able to have a user interface
to basically re-knit this report
with parameters of interest.
So you take the same parameters,
and put a front-end on it.
You can also use things
like HTML widgets,
which I mentioned before
as front-end interactivity.
So those do not require
a server back-end.
So you could publish R
Markdown document with, say
the leaflet package, which
provides a JavaScript
and HTML on the front-end.
We're able to interact and
get this Google Maps-esque,
but it's really
an OpenStreetMap,
interactivity around on maps.
There's a ton of
different HTMLwidgets.
And even things like Crosstalk,
where you can have HTMLwidgets
talk to each other
on the same web page,
even without a server.
You could always add a
server on the back-end
with Shiny runtime.
But these three links here will
cover additional HTMLwidgets
that I won't get to today.
And lastly, something of
interest and something that
I'm really excited about
is the Blastula package,
which is a way of creating
beautiful HTML emails in R
and in .Rmds.
So the basic idea
is that you can
write a basic script
or almost like an R
Markdown-esque format here of
what you want the email to say.
It can then run this email
based off of some R input.
And have an output of
this beautiful HTML
email that can
then be pushed out
through Connect automatically.
So yes, you could
create a report
that people can interact with.
You could also have
that same report
copy-pasted into an email and
sent to a specific person,
even if they're not
accessing Connect.
And so these three
things here are
something I'm going to cover
on the demo portion, which I'll
get over to here in a second.
And lastly, there
is this link here
where Kelly O'Brien
actually put together
an example of customs
scheduled emails with Blastula
and RStudio Connect.
And it's a great read through.
With this I'd like to jump over
to the demonstration point.
So let me switch screens.
Zoom in a little bit.
All right, so, for most people
hopefully this is familiar.
In terms of, this
is the RStudio IDE.
Importantly, I'm
actually accessing this
through my web browser.
So this is RStudio Server Pro.
You could technically
use the desktop IDE
and get the same
experience with publishing.
So the idea here is that
I create an application.
If I want to publish it, I can
publish it to Connect here.
By just clicking this
blue Publish button,
I take all the source code--
it finds the data that
is necessary to run
this, bundles it all together
and says, do you to publish it?
Now I've actually
published this already,
so I be updating
the existing asset.
But I would just click Publish,
and it would push all that
and reinstall the packages
onto Colorado, which
is our internal connect server.
But the idea here
is that, that's it.
That's push-button deployment.
One button pressed,
you're ready to go,
and it's pushed out there.
This example here is
a Shiny application.
This could be R
Markdown for HTML.
This could be R Markdown
for a PDF document.
Or it could be even a
xaringan Mood Reader
or xaringan for a presentation
with HTML CSS on the front-end.
So this application-- we'll just
go through the Shiny App first.
I published it onto Connect.
The basic landing page
for Connect gets me here.
So the immediate
thing of interest
is that you had your
discoverability built in.
I can see all the content I own.
I could also filter
back out and just
look at all the server content.
Going in and even searching
for, maybe I just want
to look for PDF, I could
search for PDF documents
and find things that
have been knit in PDF.
I also have a full-blown
tagging system.
So internally, we do
this around technologies.
But you could imagine a world
where, in your environment,
you actually want to filter
it out by specific teams
or by specific assets.
But the idea being
that you could
filter at many different
levels and find content that
is meaningful to you.
Additionally from an
administrative side,
you can see all the
different people
who have access to content.
You can see the different roles.
So publishers versus
viewers, so people
who can only consume that
content versus people
who publish.
All the way down
to administrators
who have additional privileges
around changing assets
that have already
been published.
I can even go in here and
lock or edit the administrator
roles for this person.
So from an access perspective,
you have full control for this.
From, not having to
go into a config file.
You also have visibility into
the use of your applications
or the use of your server.
You can see how many people
are actually on your server.
How many connections
are being used.
How much RAM and CPU of
your server is being used.
Is it getting hit a lot?
Or is it being used
at a low level?
You also have your audit logs.
You can actually see
all the different things
that have happened,
different events over time.
So you have this
visibility into things that
are occurring on your server.
With that, we have
about 15 minutes left.
So I do want to get
into the demo portion.
The first idea here is--
I've taken my existing code.
So this Access-to-care
Hospital Dashboard,
which was created by
Edgar-- one of the solutions
engineers here at RStudio.
And this has been
published onto Connect.
There's a couple of
things going on here
that I want to show you.
In terms of, this is actually
a flexdashboard setup.
So you would have a Shiny
runtime on top of that.
So because it has
a Shiny runtime,
that means you can
re-execute R code on the fly.
So I can switch between states,
and it will re-execute R code
and give me some
type of new output.
On the front-end, I actually
have an HTML widget.
So this interactivity
here, doesn't
require the server back-end.
So this could be shifted
over into a pure R Markdown
document.
I'm focusing on this example
because it's a simple example.
The basic idea is,
how many hospitals
do you need per population?
And you can see that
with our linear model
here, about 80.78 RSquared.
The idea here is that as
your population increases,
you need more hospitals.
So I'm going to be using this
example for the rest of my R
Markdown examples.
But wanted to start
with the Shiny example.
Because this is
Shiny, you have access
to the Shiny runtime in
terms of the server itself.
So you could go in here and
specify specific settings,
or you just use
a server default,
about how to scale
up this application
or how performant
you want to be.
So maybe you want it to idle out
and close down pretty quickly.
Because once people
stop using it,
you want it to free up
compute on your server.
So you could go in here
for the Shiny portion,
and change all these
different factors.
But as I mentioned
before, we really
want to focus on R Markdown.
But I just wanted to show you
that you have this ability
to change the runtime and
when you cook at a runtime,
if it's a Shiny application,
it has these options.
So I mentioned a little
bit about HTML widgets.
And I want to show you
this specific example that
is a "Hello, World"
more basic example
of HTML widgets plus Crosstalk.
So in this case, there
isn't a Shiny runtime.
So there's no server
on the back-end,
this is just the HTML front-end.
So in this case, I can actually
filter and change my graph
here without having
to re-run R code.
I published this out.
And the only thing
that's being changed
is HTML and JavaScript
on the front-end.
So all this interactivity
I have built in
doesn't require a
running Shiny example.
And you can even click here
and filter into small examples
of filtering the graph itself.
So basically the idea
here that I'm setting up
is that you're R Markdown could
be built as a Shiny component
or you could build
it out here with just
front-end interactivity.
So going back to out Access
to Care by State example.
Maybe you take that Shiny
application and you're like,
oh well, I really just
want to send out reports
to each of the state governors.
And say, hey, your state is
doing well or doing poorly,
and how many hospitals it
has for user of population.
So you can take that same
R Markdown based report,
change the output to PDF,
and publish this the Connect
as well.
So now it's hosted, it's
got authenticated access,
and only people who
are allowed to see it
can actually come in
here and access it.
You still have the table.
You still have a map.
Because it's PDF
there's no interactivity
it's just a static document.
Importantly, if I go in here
into the Connect portion,
I can see that the access
of who can actually
edit this document.
So who can change it.
Only these four people.
So Edgar could actually push
it out and then the three
collaborators.
But I've made it where
anyone can access or view
this document without
login required.
I could make this to
where users specifically
would have to login, or only
to specific users or groups.
Like say, the Administration
Team or the Exec Team.
All the way down to just the
collaborators and the owner
of the document.
Additionally, because it's
not a Shiny application,
there's no runtime.
So there's no R code being
executed continuously.
But because it's an
R Markdown document
I could still
schedule this output
to occur at a specific
time interval.
So I could say, yes, I see this
application or this report.
I want it to run once
a week for eternity.
Every week it updates the
data and creates a new report.
So I want to see
that here on Connect.
So I can schedule the report
to occur every Wednesday,
like today.
I'll have it run
weekly on Wednesday.
And I want to publish an output.
I can also send an
email after the update.
So not only does a publish
it here onto Connect,
it would actually send it to
all the collaborators, all
the viewers, or whoever
you wanted to go out to.
So having this
option of having it
be on Connect or in your inbox.
Additionally, beyond
just the pure,
I just want to see this report.
There was a lot more states
here in the Shiny application
besides just California.
Because this is a
parameterized R Markdown,
I can actually go in
here on the left tab
and change the parameters within
Connect, re-run the report,
and re-generate the output.
So I could change it to Texas,
Colorado, where I wanted to be.
Re-run the report.
And it will re-generate that.
I'll go into the HTML
widget example to show that.
Because it's a little more
fun to have the interactivity.
So PDF is great but maybe
we want to still have
some interactivity.
So now, this is still
an R Markdown document.
So there's no Shiny runtime.
But if I go in here, I can still
get front-end interactivity.
So what is the user
population there?
How many hospitals are expected
versus how many do they have?
I have a data table
down here, in terms of I
can actually click through
and adjust this data table.
I could sort by
population, alphabetically,
number of hospitals, all
of this interactivity
that's built in here.
And I don't have to use
computational resources
around the Shiny application.
You can still create a wonderful
Shiny application around this,
but just giving you
this alternative.
Importantly, you
have the same idea.
You could still schedule
this report to run.
You can see I had it where
it's running every Monday.
It actually sends me
an email every Monday
so that I get this
updated report.
Additionally, you can
save different versions.
So I live in Texas, so maybe
I want to always come back
in here and see Texas.
So I can actually save a
personal report for myself.
Just come in here and use
Texas, or go back to California,
or just go back to the
default that we see before.
And again, because it's
parameterized, I can go in here
and give it to
someone who doesn't
know how to code at all
in R, but wants to see
this report for Delaware.
So they can actually come
in here, run the report,
Connect will execute the
code, re-run the report,
re-generate it, re-knit it.
All of this.
And put it back up here
into your viewport.
And this person can
then self-service.
Provide their own analytics
or create their own reporting.
So you can take your data
science model or your data
science product that
you've created here,
create a report around it, and
then share that widely within
your organization including
people who can code or people
who cannot code.
So same idea.
It's changed the title,
it's created a new map here
for Delaware-- a lot less
counties here in Delaware--
and then again, it's got
the same interactivity
on the data table.
Yeah, so, you've got this
parameterization option.
So I could save this, but
I'm not interested in that.
I want to keep Texas
as my favorite.
Additionally, you can take
this similar R Markdown report
and knit it out to a
xaringan presentation.
So same idea.
You have a x-y coordinate
of your hospitals
versus user population.
You can look at the linear
relationship between the two.
And then actually output
the model around that.
So maybe this would be more
interesting for your data
scientists, as opposed
to your executive team.
But similarly this is built
purely from a R Markdown
report.
That's been generated out to
a xaringan, HTML, JavaScript
presentation.
It could still be scheduled
to re-run or parameterize as
needed.
Additionally,
because Connect also
allows for publishing
from Jupyter notebooks,
you can take the same data,
run similar ideas in terms
of you're looking at
population versus county level
and how many
hospitals there are.
And this is actually
a Jupyter notebook
that's been published
onto RStudio Connect.
So maybe you have a lot
of people working in R,
maybe a lot of people
working in R and Python.
Like this is
primarily Python code.
You can have Python
integrated into R Markdown
through reticulate.
Or if you actually publish
directly from your Jupyter
notebook onto Connect
through the Jupyter plugin.
So really making it
a widely used tool
regardless of the language
you bring to the table.
Moving a little bit
beyond the concept
of all these different reports.
Maybe doing some things
that would be more
along the lines of a little
bit of data engineering
or less interesting but very
necessary and useful ideas.
So here we're doing an extract,
transform, load, or ETL script.
This is run as an R
Markdown document.
It's running some R code,
generating some type of output,
creating some portfolio
ideas around stock prices.
And then it's actually
writing this out to a table
within our database.
So the idea here that you could
take this ETL script as an R
Markdown document
rather than having
to run a cron job or
manually do all this stuff.
You can just have
it automatically
update once a week, once a day,
every hour, or once a month.
However you want to schedule it.
You could have
this ETL job re-run
and prepare your data for you.
So first thing in the
morning, it's ready to go
and you don't have to go
in and do this manually.
So again, freeing you up to
do the more intellectually
rigorous stuff within your
data science environment,
as opposed to spending a lot
of time re-running things
manually.
Additionally, taking
something still
within the reporting space
or the R Markdown output,
creating this
report that's Rich.
And you look at this and
it's a useful report.
It's got some front-end
interactivity.
Again, no Shiny here.
But you have the ability
to zoom in and drill down
at specific levels.
See the model fit here, in
terms of the local line fitting.
And then how much are we
spending our customers
versus items and visits.
Regardless of the
content here, the idea
is that this is all built
from a R Markdown document.
So again, you can do
your parameterization
and specify different levels.
You could have 10 different
inputs, or however many inputs
you wanted to.
Maybe you wanted to
change the segment
to a different part of
the user population,
or a different group, or
a different time period.
Additionally, this
actually has a link
to download the report
as an Excel file.
So people are still going
to use spreadsheet software
within an organization,
it's going to happen.
But at least at
this point you've
generated it programmatically.
So you have full
visibility into it.
You've created a
report with code
so you know exactly why
and how it was created.
And now you have a file that
can be shared widely that you
have kind of visibility into.
Additionally, and again kind
of hitting on the same note,
I could send an email
about this automatically
or I could send it
to myself manually.
So taking this idea of
being able to share widely
within my organization, either
in the inbox or on Connect.
Now, the exciting
part for me is--
let me just pull
this over real quick.
So this same report
is now in my inbox.
So you can see that
this is an HTML output,
it's almost identical to
the report on Connect.
So this is just in my inbox.
I sent it to myself last night.
It has the same idea
where you still have
a graph that you can look at.
You have a full Rich
Text Format table.
You can go back to
Connect and click on it.
And even pastes in the Excel
file here in your email.
So rather than having
doing this manual request
and responding directly
to ad hoc request,
you're able to have this
data there automatically.
Or programmatically send
out these very Rich emails.
So hopefully that was it
was interesting to you all.
We are running out of time here,
with a couple of minutes left.
So I'm just going to hit on
a couple of the last slides
and point.
A lot of these examples came
from the solutions.rstudio.com
website.
Specifically, if you go here
to the by industry health care,
access to care portion.
But really importantly, this
has a lot of our best practices
for using both our RStudio
professional products,
and generally a lot
of how we're thinking
about using R and R plus
Python in your environment
to do data science at scale.
So giving you examples, scripts,
or examples of how you can
approach this on Connect.
As well as just thinking
about it in general.
Lastly, if you are interested
in learning more about Connect,
you can go here to the
rstudio.com/products/connect.
There's a free
45-day evaluation.
Where you can try it on your
own server or on the Cloud.
Or you can download a
prefigure Quickstart
where you just install
a virtual machine,
and then run it on that.
With that, I'll get back
into the slides real quick.
And I appreciate everyone
joining me here for today.
So the real core concept
here is that Connect
can help you get started,
or help you level up.
So whether you're just getting
started in your long data
science journey, you
have a small team
and you really just want to
start having a more robust data
science environment, Connect
is ready for your team
to start publishing things.
And creating assets out there
for your team to actually
have insights around.
Alternatively, if you have
a more robust data science
environment, you're starting
to use continuous integration,
you want high
availability, scaling,
with hundreds of
thousands of users,
Connect is still
ready to serve you.
So across this entire
spectrum, Connect
is a ready product for you to
help level up your data science
environment.
And this is really
harped upon here
by Sean, who's the product
manager here at RStudio.
"I see a lot of our
users feel like imposters
when production comes up.
Lots of tools and
lingos out there,
but trust me if you
can fit a model,
the rest doesn't
have to be hard.
With RStudio Connect you can
take the hard work you've
already done on your
core data science work
and take that, and take it to
the next level with R Markdown
or Shiny or Plumber or APIs
all publishing on connect.
With that, I'll leave you with
these last few slides or links,
which are the same
ones from beginning.
Basically, additional
webinars free
to take a look at specific
to administrating RStudio
as a whole, model management
and putting models in production
using RStudio Connect.
And then Shiny in
production, more
about the principles, practices,
and tools by Joe Cheng.
Additionally, Kelly O'Brien
will be giving the third webinar
in this webinar series.
And she'll be talking
a little bit more
about interactivity
and production,
including a bit of Shiny.
Lastly again, we do have 45-day
free evaluation of pro product.
So if you want to
try something out,
or you can always
book a call with us
to talk about RStudio Connect,
through rstudio.youcanbook.me.
Thanks.
With that I will go
back to questions.
Looks like one here from Steve.
When a regular R
Markdown is on Connect,
can a code be modified and
run right there in the browser
like a Jupyter notebook?
So the R Markdown itself is
executed through parameters.
So you would still
be-- if you wanted
to work with it interactively
you'd be using it either
in IDE, that's like
me with RStudio Server
Pro, or your desktop IDE.
But really the
idea of Connect is
that you've published both
the finished product as well
as the source code.
So you can still run and update
things through parameters.
But you want to have
a static input there--
a static source code I guess.
For small teams,
are there pricing
options that get you started
other than 45-days free?
So aiming at the academic
as well as small businesses,
yes, we do have an
academic discounts.
As well as small
business discounts,
depending upon your revenue.
So absolutely.
Reach out to us via
sales@rstudio.com.
And we're happy to have a
discussion around what you're
looking for.
And work around the
budget you have.
And it looks like all the rest
of the questions were answered.
So, I think we're good there.
But I appreciate y'all's
attention today and have a good
rest of your week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]